what can the newbies expect now that
they're permanent fixtures
well anna's been here you know for a
long time now they're permanent fixtures
at that table
well i think that that makes them feel
more secure you know then they're just
guests but what can they expect from you
because
listen i've been on the air for 25 years
on this show with a
not a not self and not a self-imposed
hiatus for two i just want to point that
out
um but i was here for most of the time
and um they know what to expect from me
i'm me i'm me they know joy their people
know me
they expect the same thing again and
again and again i know i was talking
right i'm talking about i'm talking
about somebody absolutely
treated me so much when i was on
maternity leave she missed fighting with
me
i did not miss you we saw that again and
again and again between you and megan
mccain so are you expecting a little bit
of that banter with alyssa here no
alyssa's got a whole different
personality
so i think it'll be smoother frankly
yeah we'll see i mean i like both of
them but i i think this girl is going to
do very well i call her a girl because
she's only 32 years old right so she can
still be a girl anyway i consider that a
compliment when someone says you're a
girl yes i'll take it for the rest of my
life i'm getting ma'am now and i'm like
no i'm here to just join this table
hopefully bring a different perspective
listen it's going to get sporty
sometimes but i adore women
i'm so excited for i'm ready for it what
can or have you shared when it comes to
advice
to these new co-hosts
yes they've been around we've seen
alyssa 29 times it was a broken record
for a long time because i called i say
this show is a volleyball game it's not
a golf game so if you know to hit the
ball and then wait for it to come back
at you and all that you'll be fine
that's the only advice i ever give
anybody really how much pool do you
ladies have about who's going to be a
permanent fixture as a co-host on the
show i think i think that you know we
have some input but it's really the
ultimate decision is not up to us yeah
no it's not up to you not even the og
host
they listen believe me they're never
going to say oh because joyce said it
don't even wait for that this show set
out as you all know barbara walters had
this vision for bringing women from
totally different backgrounds lived
experiences careers to talk about the
tough issues that frankly our elected
officials often aren't tackling and we
do that every day and we're having
important conversations i am so proud to
have found my voice things get a little
personal from time to time yesterday you
shared about your
topic pregnancy yeah
do you were very personal yesterday in
1979 i had an ectopic pregnancy they
rushed me to the hospital i was the
doctor the next day said we almost lost
you right because i was well and i was
in the situation where i could go to
beth israel hospital and they took care
of it there i will share things that i
think are helpful i've been divorced
i've been married two times i have a
child i have a grandchild i had this
terrible time when i had that eczema
pregnancy and we're in the middle of a
crisis in this country with roe v wade
and there are people out there
and they know who they are who confuse
miscarriage with ectopic pregnancies i
mean it's crazy i i know i i was there i
must died that uh embryo is not going to
live in that fallopian tube so let's
let's not pretend it is
and so i wanted to uh people to
understand that that they need to look
into this more more compassionately and
more clearly and more scientifically and
stop making things up so that's why i
shared that
[Music]
you